[Music]
in one in a million chance news
submitted by you know nothing a 23 year
old suffered a stroke after casually
cracking her neck in bed I better tell
Mary we'll stop that [ __ ] she like be
cracking her [ __ ] neck all the time
dude I packed my neck all the time
how do your terribly just swing it
around really yeah it's like rocking her
like your knuckles you know the trip
with this one she didn't even do it on
purpose she accidentally happened and
when she cracked it she punctured an
artery which led to having blood go
rushed up to her brain and she had a
stroke like instantly not instantly yeah
she's only 23 how can you be so [ __ ]
fragile I'm confused why you're cracking
up so hard
regular cuz she cracked she okay she's
okay so what happened was Natalie was in
bed watching a movie and was she just
like all of a sudden just kind of moved
she cracked like a freak accident
it was a definite freak out that
shouldn't happen right cuz your neck
cracks are just supposed to be gasp
released between your joints yeah so the
fact that it affected the arteries kind
of weird yeah I ruptured a major artery
what if she was just binge watching Game
of Thrones and she was in one position
for too long and then she finally
cracked it the way they come up with
[ __ ] story plots and all that [ __ ]
you do like Joel
I know what Ghadir asked the red wedding
gotta rap that's what happens there we
go there you go and it should crack her
neck Seema's not caught up in I'm the
only one that's not caught up in because
all these guys have been talking about
for the last half an hour just have
diarrhea for five days all right so then
she said that she got up to go to the
bathroom 15 minutes later because at
that moment she didn't think nothing of
it
but then that's what she collapsed the
floor she was unable to move her left
leg that's up boy Sankofa and her
roommate she said friend and it was a
guy oh my god they were [ __ ] he was
giving her dagestan in her hair
what happened Oh watching the movie man
you were having rough sex I was thinking
that too I'm like this was sex and news
like no we just moved no science for the
sake of science she'd be like yeah he
was hitting it with the back what was
the crack is it from something like
whiplash or something like this yeah he
was pulling her hair really hard cuz if
it was from her neck being pulled back
his history works out that doggy style
he was pulling the hair yeah any [ __ ]
k mistake I'm actually surprised that
more strokes haven't happened that way
yeah now that I know it's apparently
that easy it's like detective Joe here
to solve the mystery you know when you
get doggy style make that like you guys
are saying yeah yeah when the ladies get
the doggy style but you're standing up
and then your face is pressed against
the wall like this and your hands are
pressed against the wall like that and
you can [ __ ] slap like that yeah
that's probably what happened I thought
you were gonna ask a question sound like
yeah no I just wanted to do it for us I
found it be I can't find show where this
guy would watch again you start
stripping on the scene watch this he
just takes one of his [ __ ] okay
something first though he goes I know
how this happened then he gets naked
come Watson we get the zach galifianakis
shot where he's like got all the
equations in the back he's figuring it
out yeah hangover oh you'll be like a
good doctor do ya I'll have my assistant
ain't agent Jessica come here and then
we'll / we'll we'll do it on scene to
recreate the steps of what happened to a
porno done the very least it's a very
engaging porno with a very unique
premise so you could tell he held it
right at his [ __ ] is it time I think
Jones just trying to find an excuse to
[ __ ] in public there's not even blood
splatters come splatters that bleach so
she's a paramedic student or a paramedic
and so she's saying that once she call
9-1-1 they thought that maybe she was
drunk
or like something was wrong with her and
she was like no okay she's learning her
works yeah she was like no I know
something's wrong like I need to be
taken to the hospital and then that's
when they found out what happened to her
whoa two different people
nine-one-one needs to come up with
another thing we're like if you can't
talk then what do you do like if you
could only type in 911 like use your
voice cuz you just got your don't they
just send people out they send people no
matter what yeah I would like to do like
nine one one and then like go nine or
something or like type with the 89 no
but if it's a if it's one of those home
phone all right I mean you should press
nine it's equal to how urgent it is on a
scale of one to ten so you should do
that looked like she got a baby on her
titty yeah oh yeah I did think it was a
bit of [ __ ] that it wasn't I don't know
yeah then this is her trying to like
recuperate damn whole left side is
paralyzed it looks like every single
picture it's a different woman who knows
so it's not permanent or like there were
think about for a minute they were able
to do a stint to help with the blood
clot but not completely so she's
supposed to do a lot of therapy to try
to get back to 100% she mad at her
boyfriend for dog installer to heart
still she looks she looks like different
people on every single picture every
single one yeah baby somebody that's
been paralyzed on half their face yeah
that is [ __ ] hilarious tur the one
before john crichton arose from the
that's reball palsy or palsy it's known
as Bell's do oh yeah Bell's palsy friend
uh Daniel woo in high school he got his
face paralyzed from I forgot what was
like from stress or some [ __ ] right oh
my god he forgot and we're at lunch and
drink water shoe on one side no bad but
I wasn't tears laughing but like I said
okay see what smiled like you have
depend what side you're on because one
side with some on the other one wouldn't
ya know she would kiss me really we how
long did it last
it just went away one day thank goodness
why you wouldn't love them yeah that's
my girl my friends to phase yeah when
you get turtle one side of the [ __ ] your
happy face I want the other face it
lastly like about a month or a month and
a half that was like this nerve behind
your ear it's like a pinched nervous
yeah I was a pinched nerve and that
completely like paralyzed the whole time
what before did that happen to him she
was like blowing his nose really really
hard like blowing it to child he did
that to himself he was doing this
and they're shooting all the books by
then I should burst in his [ __ ] it was
like really hard that's what Bart does
he always gives himself nosebleeds
always do them to myself they just
happen later on because they're too
rough
that's very rough bursting blood vessels
every time you blow your nose every time
he rubs his eyes brush his teeth wash
his face wash his butthole
I think anything when it goes through
himself it's very rough like he wants to
get rid of that part I'm trying to be a
good cleaner dude you're a [ __ ] lupus
is the back of razors really he clean
this but butthole by sticking his finger
and then he says he bends it why would
you do that to yourself did I do it like
a periscope I gonna stop her oh my god
do you get a lot of [ __ ] out with your
nailers no my bubbles always cleaning
that's why I don't know that's too much
actually self cleaning but you said is
grandma's hot huh that's like when you
pick your nose instead of just going
here you go all the way up to your sinus
and digs inside now you understand fart
well extra man yeah that's like brushing
your teeth Oh like what are your teeth
and it going extra and going deep
throwing it
why would you stick this weekend you the
nurse practitioner was actually really
impressed cuz so we had to get strep
throat test yeah they have to stick a
cotton swab in the back of the throat
and you did a gag yeah he's like oh [ __ ]
he's so you don't like usually no one
does this do i a deep throat I was like
what's because I usually scratch the
back of my throat with my tooth off the
top you [ __ ] brush your tonsils well
sometimes the itch is so I just scratch
the bud extreme amount of lacerations in
the back of your throat have you been
sucking a lot of take recently oh [ __ ]
at the back sound like brushes his teeth
that at night thank you the definition
of extra mile man this morning I was
using the Waterpik and I don't I mean I
don't use it that often I usually just
use a string thing but I recently got it
for Isaac with his braces and smell like
hell is doing it right you're supposed
to have your mouth open cuz the water's
cost is it better than the floss I don't
know what is it that it's a better
finish telling your story before you
start trying to buy one I'm right there
with you I don't notice that what a
water cake a cake is like a super strong
jet of water that goes between your
teeth to clean it okay I do that yeah I
guess it is so I was using it and then I
think because I don't use it that often
I held it in my mouth cuz I I was doing
this in my hair right and then the
frickin water pick here and there's like
gushing water I had to turn it off so I
did this but I I don't know I'm stupid
so I held it in my mouth it was
don't like water splashing everyone's
like [ __ ] I gotta go to ticket oh no but
that stream doesn't have bad breath
anymore it's all clean
anymore did you just [ __ ] water
picked your mouth and you threw up back
in your mouth no but that [ __ ] it hurt
so I reminded me of that when you're
saying you're scratching the back of
your tonsil you should just get a water
pick and just like aim it I have a
scratch on my fingernail sometimes the
itch isn't back there wait why does your
throat itch like that though I don't
know most people eat your throat hmm
bro nobody [ __ ] it goes like this
okay well excuse me one sec good I have
a sore throat you want a cop drop nah
guys let's continue this meeting
[Music]
[Music]